hello and welcome back in this week
we're going to go over the basics of
neural network programming it turns out
that when you implement a neural network
there are some implementation techniques
that are going to be really important
for example if you have a training set
of M training examples you might be used
to processing the training set by having
a for loop step through your M training
examples but it turns out that when you
implement it in your network you usually
want to process your entire training set
without using an explicit for loop to
loop over your entire training set so
you see how to do that in this week's
materials another idea when you organize
the computation of a new network usually
you have what's called a forward
password for propagation set followed by
a backward pass or what's called a
backward propagation step and so in this
week's material
you also get an intuition about why the
computations in learning in a neural
network can be organized in this board
propagation and a separate backward
propagation for this week's materials I
want to convey these ideas using
logistic regression in order to make the
ideas easier to understand but even if
you've seen logistic regression before I
think that there will be some new and
interesting ideas for you to pick up in
this week's material so that let's get
started logistic regression is an
algorithm for binary classification so
let's start by setting up the problem
here's an example of a binary
classification problem you might have an
input of an image like that and one to
output a label to recognize this image
as being either a cat in which case you
output one or non-cat in which case you
hope with zero and we're going to use Y
to denote the output label let's look at
how an image is represented in a
computer to store an image your computer
suppose three separate matrices
corresponding to the red green and blue
color channels of this image so if your
input image is 60
four pixels by 64 pixels then you would
have three 64 by 64 matrices
corresponding to the red green and blue
pixel intensity values for your image
although to make these from a slide I
drew these as much smaller matrices so
these are actually 5 by 4 matrices
rather than 64 by 64 so to turn these
pixel intensity values into a feature
vector what we're going to do is unroll
all of these pixel values into a input
feature vector X so to unroll all of
these pixel intensity values into a
feature vector what we're going to do is
define a feature vector X corresponding
to this dimension as follows which is
going to take all the pixel values 2 5 5
2 3 1 and so on 2 5 5 2 3 1 and so on
until we've listed all the red pixels
and then eventually to 5 5 1 3 4 2 5 5 1
3 4 and so on until we get a very long
feature vector listing out all the red
green and blue pixel intensity values of
this image so if this image is a 64 by
64 image the total dimension of this
vector X will be 64 by 64 by 3 because
that the total numbers we have in all of
these matrices which in this case turns
out to be 1 2 2 8 8 that's what you get
if you multiply out those numbers and so
we're going to use n x equals 1 2 2 8 8
to represent the dimension of the input
features X and sometimes for brevity and
also just use lowercase n to represent
the dimension of this input feature
vector
so in binary classification our goal is
to learn a classifier that can input an
image represented by this feature vector
X and predict whether the corresponding
label Y is 1 or 0 that is whether this
is a cat image or non cat image let's
now lay out some of the notation that
we'll use throughout the rest of this
course a single training example is
represented by a pair
X comma Y where X is an N X dimensional
feature vector and Y the label is either
0 or 1 your training set will comprise
lowercase M training examples and so
your training sets will be written x1
comma y1 which is the input and output
for your first training example x2 comma
y2 for a second training example up to X
M comma Y M which is the last training
example and then that altogether this
your entire training set so I'm going to
use lowercase M to denote the number of
training examples and sometimes to
emphasize that this is the number of
training examples I might write this as
M subscript train and when we talk about
a test set we might sometimes use M
subscript test to denote the number of
test examples so that's the number of
test examples finally to put all of the
training examples into a more compact
notation we're going to define a matrix
capital X as defined by taking your
training set inputs x1 x2 and so on and
stacking them in columns so if you take
x1 and you put that as the first column
of this matrix and x2 cordetta the
second column and so on down to X M then
this is the matrix capital X so this
matrix X will have M columns where m is
the number of training examples and the
number of rows or the height of this
matrix is NX notice that in other causes
you might see the matrix capital X
defined by stacking up the training
examples in rows like so X 1 transpose
down to X M transpose but it turns out
that when you're implementing neural
networks using this convention I have on
the left will make the implementation
much easier so just to recap X is a n X
by M dimensional matrix and when you
compliment this
Pisan you see that ex-parte shape that
the Python command for finding the shape
of the matrix that this is M and X comma
M this just means is in NX by M
dimensional matrix so that's how you
group the training examples input X into
matrix how about the output labels Y it
turns out that to make your
implementation of a neural network
easier I'll be convenient also stack Y
in columns so we're going to define
capital Y to be equal to Y 1 y 2 up to Y
M like so so Y here will be a 1 by M
dimensional matrix and again to use the
Python notation you know the shape of Y
will be 1 comma M which just means this
is a 1 by M matrix and as you implement
your neural network later in this course
you find that a useful convention will
be to take the data associate to a
different training example and by data I
mean either X or Y or other quantities
you see later but to take the stuff or
the data associated with different
training examples and to stack them in
different columns like we've done here
for both x and y so that's the notation
we'll use for logistic regression and
for neural networks later in this course
if you ever forget what a piece of
notation means like what is M or 1 is n
or 1 or something else we've also posted
on the course website
in notation guide you can use to quickly
look up what you know any particular
piece of notation means so that lets go
on to the next video we'll start to
flesh out logistic regression using this
notation